yo's happening my is Mar i hope you
enjoyed our acoustic version on in
Alexander plat in Berlin it was one of
my favite Performances everyone gathered
around it was cool we were on the
underground love whatck do it looked
amazing yeah so stay tuned here chr has
a very Speci Speci
for tell you what that Ising up than you
so
ja vielen Dank Marlon ich fand deinen
sweet KCK in Berlin auch sensationell
und sensationell ist auch unser kleines
Special für Maron rodet ihr könnt
nämlich Tickets gewinnen für die kurze
aber exklusive Tour von Maron rudet
durch Deutschland am 16.12 in Berlin
zwei Tickets am 18.12 in Köln zwei
Tickets und am 19.12 in Frankfurt zwei
Tickets und alles was ihr machen müsst
ist an unserem kleinen legendär en
Adventskalender Spielchen teilnehmen das
ganze findet ja auf dem Kanaldesign von
klixum stad da immer die Zahlen merken
also vor allen Dingen heute hingucken
und ab morgen werden dann die Lösung für
diese Tickets eingesammelt das heißt am
10.12 am 11.12 und am 12.12 könnt ihr
dran teilnehmen sagt die ges schreibt
uns an
klickung@gmail.com die gewünschte Zahl
achtet heute auch schon mal drauf was im
Kanaldesign steht und dann kann
eigentlich nichts mehr schiefgehen hier
unten ist üens noch mal das Erklärvideo
für das
adventskalenderpiel verlinkt jo und dann
kann ich eigentlich nur noch wie
wimtölke wer nicht kennt googelen sagen
viel
Glück